كالكثير من اللبنانيين لا يملك شارل
القدره الماديه لدفع اشتراك القناه
المتلفزه او مشاهده المباريات في احد
المطاعم فقرر الاستعانه بتطبيق غير قانوني
ليفتح النافذه مجانيه على الملاعب القطريه
واكله وشربته داونلود يعني وفي كود نزل
حتى الكود ودغري نزلت عنده عم تعطيني
تقريبا كل الطوشه اللبنانيه
الشبان لا يستطيعون متابعه الحدث العالمي
حشد محمد واصدقائه طاقتهم لمنح سكان الحي
الذي يقطن فيه فرصه مشاهده المونديال في
الشارع مجانا
الماتش
الابطال ونحيي العرب ونحيي كل دول العالم
هلا اذا بدك تروح على القهوه ارجيله
ومشروب يعني بقت كلفك على الواحد 150,000
فا اذا بتحضروا هون يعني حق ارجيله بتقعد
ماسك بالنسبه الى القسم الاكبر من
اللبنانيين مونديال هذا العام اكثر من
مجرد ترفيه فهو بمثابه هروب من مشاكلهم
اليوميه في بلد يعاني من ازمه اقتصاديه
غير مسبوقه